is my only option to do it on my own so
I have a great question from one of my
youtube viewers Jeremy who wrote in to
say hello Evan great videos always
you're my favorite guru well thanks
Jeremy I need help I have an idea for
recording a short drama music video but
I don't know anyone reliable enough who
has a creativity or understanding to
help me shoot the video and I don't have
the funds a higher professional
videographer crew what can I do is my
only option to do it all on my own
Jeremy welcome to the world of
entrepreneurship right we never have the
resources we need to make our vision
happen and entrepreneur is the
difference what makes a successful
entrepreneur is you find a way you find
a way the bootstrap this thing up and
make your dream happen when all logical
things say this is never going to happen
ok so here are some options for you you
want to make this video happen here are
a few options you can try first off get
a clear vision ok I would research other
videos other productions that you look
at that you like and try to identify the
elements of those videos that you really
like but there's tons of videos online
go to youtube start your search pull out
elements and make a list to say you know
from 10 seconds to 20 seconds I really
like how they do this so that the more
specific you can get the better second
thing is go out and start networking
with people who believe in the same
thing as you I don't know what this
video is all about right you need to do
a good job of explaining the big vision
behind it why are you doing this why is
this so important to you what big thing
you try to accomplish because if your
video stands for something that has
meaning that it's going to have an
impact on this world that people will
want to be a part of it but you have to
explain what you're doing so for example
I like to salsa dance ok and recently
this morning a salsa band wrote to me
they're launching a new song and they're
they're bringing in people from around
the world and they're asking them can
you please dance on camera to all the
part of the song because they want to
make a music video combining all the
dances from around the world
with our song this is a pretty cool
project and it's a nice song so I'm
thinking of going with my dance partner
to Toronto Island so I can film the
scene tower behind and I'll dancer the
song and hopefully be part of their
video why am i doing I'm doing this for
free right I gotta take time to go to
Toronto Ireland travel there come up
with you know what I'm going to dance to
it's just going to take like the whole
day to do why am I willing to do that
because it's fun because it's different
because it's going to have an impact and
it's free right I'm not getting paid to
do this so people will join your cause
if they feel like they're doing
something important so explain it right
and and start hanging around people
networking online offline with people
who could potentially help you in the
video space okay number three though is
don't let the lack of a video editor
hold you back get started because too
many times entrepreneurs are launching a
product at me say off I only had this
and I could make it or until I get the
funding or until i get the partner until
i get the sponsorship i'm not going to
do anything that's not how it works you
got to start creating momentum you got
to start building this thing up and it
may mean you do the whole thing yourself
but start like don't let the lack of
resources or capital or people or ideas
hold you back from getting this thing
sir because this is only one project man
you've got a long future ahead of you of
great things this is one project to kick
you off so one research do your homework
background find all the elements that
you love that you want to include to
make this thing important start hanging
out and introducing it to people who are
in the video space may be able to help
you out and then three just get started
do something every day to make this
thing go a little bit further and don't
let the lack of anything hold you back
because what entrepreneurs are great at
is turning nothing turning an idea into
something special this is your first
challenge believe those are you watching
i love to hear what you have to think
how did you find the people the
resources to make your first idea happen
leave it in the comments section below
i'm curious to learn and it's also going
to help inspire other people so leave it
below you like this video give it a
thumbs up makes you want to do more for
you
and click on my face to subscribe to the
channel see more videos like this thank
you so much I'll see you soon